could you come up with a slogan for
Hillary's campaign I hear she wants it
to come from you guys yeah hey why not
when I get on board hey why not get on
board for the the Hillary train with the
Hillary trying that's really a I think
that would I think she would win him she
used that I think she's gonna love it
what are your thoughts on her logo we
have it right here looks good it's good
smart yeah I like it she certainly paid
her dues so she has the right to be
President if anybody does as far as I'm
concerned I don't understand it I see
the arrow going backwards rather than
forward yeah in a way it kind of is like
I'm with stupid you know what I mean
Hillary slogan should just be seriously
I got this he deserves the job if she
wants it and let's help her what do you
think about our logo disappoint you to
the left of the right that arrow is
going to the right when I look at it not
a great logo I mean who cares what the
logo in I mean is that cool I mean is
that what's gonna make our president
this is not what our presidents about a
president about making a country better
you guys have any suggestions on who
should be Hillary's running me when free
I'm just saying we get free stuff all
the time don't you realize I don't know
I guess you'd be great if I Pauly Shore
jumped in there something that'd be fun
that'd be a fun presidential present any
ideas for what Hillary slogan should be
still killing it yeah boom boom hey
Lenore I'm here baby
I have a very dirty joke about that
which you i'm sure you probably can't
put on television let's hear it why
can't Hillary Clinton get elected why
not America doesn't want another bush in
the White House think about it okay I
don't know if we could use a turn up